Ми дослідили дані, де це відео було відзнято, - в містечку Паранд.
А оскільки ми точно знаємо, де це відео зробили,
ми можемо побачити, де, власне, відбувся вибух,
тому що можна дослідити траєкторію польоту.
Зображення фрагментів ракет також поширюються
в інтернеті. Що відомо про справжність цих фото?
Є дві фотографії, що показують дві частини ракет.
Вони не верифіковані. Немає геолокації, і ми
не можемо точно визначити, де були зроблені ці знімки,
тож вони залишаються не верифікованими.
Припускається, що використали дві ракети,
щоби збити цей літак, принаймні такі дані розвідки.
Також є повідомлення, що для того, щоб розчистити
місце катастрофи, застосовують бульдозери.
А про що свідчить ваше розслідування?
Ми почали займатися цим учора
Це повідомлення нас дуже занепокоїло, бо немає
необхідності здійснювати розчистку бульдозерами
для розслідування. Ми почули про це з новин,
від журналістів, які могли бути на місці трагедії.
Схоже, що уламки літака просто прибрали з місця катастрофи.
Я вважаю, що це зашкодить розслідуванню.
Зважаючи на докази, які Bellingcat вдалося зібрати,
яка все ж таки причина падіння цього літака?
Я би не хотів говорити нічого, що ми не можемо підтвердити.
У нас є відео, яке показує вибух над містом Паранд.
Схоже, що ми бачимо ракету і потенційний об'єкт,
можливо, літак, що летить поруч. Цей вибух
співпадає з траєкторією польоту українського літака.
Це все, що я можу поки сказати, і це те, що ми підтвердили.
Нічого більшого я не можу сказати без подальшої інформації.
Зважаючи на зібрані Вами дані,
Ви все ще не виключаєте іранської версії про несправність літака?
Я не можу це виключати, але мені дуже цікаво
подивитися, на чому ґрунтується така інформація.
Тому що на даний момент, згідно з доступною нам інформацією,
багато що вказує на те, що, найімовірніше, літак був збитий.